[Music]
like potatoes you could do so much with
them you could hard boil them poach em
scramble them sunny-side up we call them
tippy eggs Yugi at home the bread will
dip yeah old dippin e is there a
condiment more than there an individual
food if I matter like a breakfast
restaurant I'll usually get one of those
like everything's and the egg I feel
like is the mortar that holds it
together I don't order eggs out because
I can make them at home unless it's a
poached egg I can't poach an egg I
wonder if we've got a gadget today
that'll help us the neg a reason why I
stopped eating hard-boiled eggs was it's
really a pain to show it's dishwasher
safe just add a little water
I'm guessing to that line is there a
line in there there's a kind of a line
halfway through there is no other line
just the top of the bottom does it
matter
the water level that seems like a lot of
water feels incorrect shaking should be
vigorous enough to fracture the shale
and membrane yeah membrane yack I think
this way maybe it's going all over the
place there's a lot of water shake after
pour or so shake oh so it's quick
there's chunks of egg disability
[Applause]
how's the egg using this so okay we
damage the egg quite a bit there's still
some good pieces down though he could
fish out card to know where the water
ends and the egg begins the dishwasher
nope well I did be there boy does a POV
it sure does
it's called the Rolly it's gotten us no
stick grip no stick grip but we got no
sticks pray I immediately have a
question is this supposed to be the egg
so this is like grab and go right you
folks take it with you put it on thermos
with eggs plug this into your car as
you're driving down the road just
munching off the egg as it rises out let
it important' they must be coloured
inside the cooking chamber with nonstick
cooking spray
all right it's cooking the Pam get the
eggs
it's okay so that's the top of the egg
one of these yeah
is there none but there are two lights
the red ones on okay which I think means
don't eat it oh oh I'm feeling a little
cooking it really does feel like you've
got an alien here that is like suffering
and dying it does feel like it's coming
out a little though
we're over to give it up now Oh nope
exceeds not done yet fix it fix it the
plunger get the plunger that looks like
a dawn egg seems to like cooking and
stuff and then cooking and stop I heard
something she's just still cooking oh
this is not good get out of here what
are you afraid of you coward oh we did
not do a good job of cleaning this
that's a full thing of plastic oh how
did we mess this up it seems so easy oh
god good chew what do we got here a
rapid egg cooker whatever is on that
finger is gonna go into the egg there's
nothing on that finger but hard work I
don't think we should read directions
okey but it's pretty much the same level
as medium this is just like a little
steamer and we got a piercing and then
we just lid on and now we wait
this is literally a video where we watch
boiling water I was hoping it was gonna
spin or something
so this is just gonna hard boil these in
6 minutes I'm pretty suspicious I
literally just had egg food poisoning I
thought is in so much pain on the ground
I took a nap on the bathroom oh god we
can get radiation poisoning we skipped a
couple steps we need water
how long does it normally take to heart
boil an egg takes me about two and a
half days very hard egg it just started
beeping again I just take him out voila
YUM that's hot Oh beautiful she feels
well no that's like more of a medium to
a soft you can tell until you started yo
open it yep feel soft that is there's
like an egg yeah it really does I'm just
scared I've been burned both about this
egg and eggs in general if I'm gonna buy
a gadget to make things easier the
gadget has to be the simplest thing in
the entire earth to use which to be fair
there's only four steps and we really
missed you all of that it says right
from the beginning here's the button
above each egg
sorry mister egg cooker we failed you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]